the uh latest so the latest
one of the latest um scapegoats
for the
anti-fact
republican right wing has been electric
vehicles
electric vehicles are seen
as counter to
big boy patriotic oil burning
fords and chevys and dodge vehicles
uh electric vehicles are seen as [ __ ]
stuff in fact i've actually told stories
of
so often it will happen
that when i uh show up at a parking lot
and park my electric vehicle
for two reasons one i tend to park as
far from wherever i'm going as possible
in the parking lot just to walk as much
as possible so even if there's a spot
right up front i'll park at the back of
the lot
just to get more more exercise please
folks uh and also just so my car doesn't
get bashed up i'll usually park pretty
far from other vehicles and far from the
stores
very often i will come out and find a
domestic pickup truck lifted
with a vile exhaust
parked right next to my car even though
i'm near nobody and i know it's an
intimidation game i know that the truck
drivers must know
that i know that they have large
genitals and it's a penis-sized contest
with these large trucks okay you get the
gist of it the the idea is the electric
vehicles are not manly and all of these
different things even though they're way
faster than all of these gas-powered
vehicles but the new thing about it is
the electric vehicles are terrible for
the country we don't have enough
electricity for them
and what about the batteries and what
about the oil companies and what about
the car dealers even though now every
brand is selling vehicles and they're
selling them at their dealerships it's
not just buy online tesla type vehicles
so now marjorie taylor green is
escalating her attack on electric
vehicles and she's doing so you may or
may not be shocked to hear this
based on
claims that are completely invalid let's
take a listen and then discuss new deal
they want every single american driving
an electric vehicle and then they have
no plan in place for an energy structure
across america that can actually supply
enough electricity to charge all these
electric vehicles oh this is going to
fail us it's not just going to fail us
it's going to cause blackouts it's going
to cause deaths people are going to die
it's going to cause americans to not be
able to function like we always have it
it's going to send us back into the dark
ages that's what the democrats are doing
yep we're going to be back in the dark
ages where all you could have was v8s
burning gas
everything she's saying is untrue
everything she's saying is completely
not based in fact not based in reality
whatsoever the truth is the electrical
system that's putting people at risk of
death
is the texas electrical system that is
by choice isolated from surrounding
grids that is the electrical system that
risks uh people people dying so here's
the way that they like to play this up
they say if everybody today
switched over to an electric vehicle
the grid wouldn't be able to handle it
and to some degree that's true but
nobody
everybody can't switch over today to
electric vehicles
most electric vehicles have months if
not years
of wait times there's waiting lists
rivien has a multi-year waiting list
last i checked about six months ago and
so there is actually a plan for the grid
to be able to support more electric
vehicles and the idea is that over time
as more electric vehicles are purchased
remember supply and demand the free
market
circumstances will react to increased
demand
it will become more advantageous to put
solar panels on your roof the way that i
have
in order to
fuel the grid
battery technology to store solar power
is going to come down in terms of price
which it already is
and we actually already know the answer
and i've talked about it before over
time we want to move buildings to being
almost like self-contained power plants
that use the most efficient technology
for heating and cooling and for cooking
and also will be able to charge the
electric vehicles that increasingly will
be there now a lot of people are going
to say david these vehicles are
expensive and induction ovens are
expensive and solar panels are expensive
and heat pump mini split systems are
expensive it's all expensive but there
is a plan in place which is over time
with incentives you get off of burning
fossil fuels to power all of this
different stuff and the building you put
solar panels on top
and then you switch over
to efficient heat pump heating and
cooling systems and you get off of gas
for cooking and you've got
low energy consumption induction
cooktops with convection ovens and then
you've got a vehicle charger and the
electric vehicle
and and we're in really good shape now
i'm minimizing the scope of that change
in the united states but the point here
is
over time as the demand for the electric
vehicles increases all of these other
things are going to happen there's also
a very interesting statistic which is if
80 of all passenger vehicles became
electric right four out of five
you would only see a 10 to 15 percent
increase in electricity consumption
so the the idea that it's as crazy as
marjorie taylor green is making it out
to be is also wrong and then lastly
there's another really important thing
electric vehicles on a per mile basis
are way more efficient than internal
combustion engines engines so over time
if the move is from internal combustion
engines to electric vehicles the demand
for electricity will go up yes but we
have clean ways of generating that
electricity but the total energy used by
passenger vehicles will go down
because the electric vehicles are so
much more efficient so this is all
fear-mongering
it's fear-mongering based on the false
notion that electric vehicles or some
kind of
[ __ ] woke green agenda meant to
whatever it's just logical
if you if you care about fast cars
electric vehicles are very very fast if
you care about spending less on powering
the vehicles with expensive gasoline
that they talk about the electrical
vehicles are better it's better all
around and the fact that they are now
focused on it and obsessed with it
tells us a lot about the real threat
that electric vehicles uh uh
put
um on the status quo energy companies
and uh that's a good thing it's actually
a very good thing